let's return to the asteroids repository
from the previous lesson do you remember
the bug you saw where you could shoot
without a delay you now have the
knowledge you need to fix that bug and
commit your fix first I'll do a git log
now I'll scroll down to the commit where
you found the bug had been introduced
you may recall that it was this commit
to double check I'll use diff to compare
it to the previous one sure enough this
commit removed the line this stop delay
before bullet equals 10 I want to riad
this line so I'll go ahead and copy it
and I can see that it should be added
inside the if statement this dot delay
before bullet is less than or equal to
zero
I'll open game J is in sublime search
for delay before bullet and hit find
until I find the appropriate if
statement here it is so I'll insert the
line now I'm ready to add the file to
the staging area and then commit it
first I'll use git status and I can see
that game J's has been modified and that
the changes are not staged yet which
means they are not in the staging area
right now I remember exactly what
changes I've made to game dot J's since
I made them just a minute ago but often
I'll find myself making changes taking a
break and then coming back and
forgetting what changes I've made so I'm
going to show you how to use git diff to
see the exact changes that you've
introduced since committing to make the
illustration more clear I'm also going
to introduce a change to index dot HTML
that I don't want to commit yet I'll
just collapse this line on to the
previous line let's think about what the
working directory staging area and
repository look like right now the
repository contains several commits and
each commit contains several files I'll
focus on the most recent commit and the
files game das and index.html the
staging area is a copy of the most
recent commit until I add changes to it
so it has those same files finally the
working directory also has the same
files in it but I've made some updates
to game J s and index dot HTML which
I'll represent using these stars you
know that you can use git diff to
compare two commits by entering their
commit IDs but the staging area and the
working directory are not commits so
they don't have IDs however it's very
common for get users to want to compare
the
working directory to the staging area so
get diff with no arguments we'll do that
this will show any changes you've made
that you haven't added to the staging
area yet so I'll go ahead and run git
diff with no arguments and I can see the
two changes I just introduced here's the
change to game jas where I riad AddThis
a before bullet and here's the change to
index.html where I combined two lines
into one now I'll add game dot jeaious
to the staging area and run git diff
again this time I only see the changes
to index.html since game J s is the same
in the staging area and the working
directory now now the staging area
contains the updated version of game J s
but not of index.html that's why when I
use to get diff to compare these two I
only saw the changes to index.html now
you might also want to view the
difference between the staging area and
the most recent commit I like to do this
right before I commit to double-check
that the files I've added are really
what I want to put in the commit the
command for this is git diff - - stage
if I run this command now I should see
the changes to game dot J s but not
index dot HTML since index dot HTML is
still the same sure enough git diff - -
stage shows only the change to game Jas
this is exactly what I want to commit so
I'll go ahead and type git commit and
I'll use the message add delay back to
bullets now I'll run git diff again and
I'll still see the changes to index dot
HTML since I haven't committed those if
I run git diff - - stage though I see
nothing since I did just commit
everything in the staging area finally I
don't actually want these changes to
index that HTML anymore to get rid of
them I'll run git reset - - hard which
discards any changes in either the
working directory or the staging area
but be very careful if you ever run this
most actions in get are reversible since
you can always restore previous commits
but you've never committed the changes
in your working directory or staging
area so if you run this command you
can't get those changes back in this
case I had just run both git diff and
get diff - - staged so I know exactly
what
changes are in the working directory and
staging area and I'm sure I don't want
them anymore now I'll run git diff again
and there are no changes what two
versions of your files does each form of
git dis compare for each form of git
diff fill in the two versions it
compares in these boxes each box should
contain either working directory staging
area commit 1 or commit to note that
commit 1 is the most recent commit in
this repository